how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and as
we get closer and closer to the end of
the year
hoping for that spider-man 3 teaser we
are still getting more and more news
about spider-man 3.
now we know that marvel and sony are
pretty much going all
out with this film if even half of the
cast that is rumored to be a part of
this film ends up showing up
in the movie it will be completely
insane and today we get to throw in two
more names for the rumor mill for
spider-man 3 cameos
the one and only tom hardy as venom and
jared litto as morbius now since
spider-man 3 is supposed to introduce
the spider-verse these choices make
perfect sense especially venom
and venom will be a great addition
because if we are doing a live-action
spider-verse
venom wasn't in the animated into the
spider-verse film
in into the spider-verse we got a little
taste of what a spider-verse would be
like
and now we're getting a live-action one
and it's super exciting but we don't
want it to be exactly the same as
into the spider verse so having venom
appear in spider-man 3
would be a very very good touch but
today isn't the first time that it's
been rumored that venom and possibly
morbius could show up
in the mcu and if we take a look back we
actually kind of have proof to this
already the morbius trailer actually
connected morbius and the sp umc the
sony picture universe of
marvel characters to the spider-man
homecoming movies therefore connecting
it to the mcu as well
as i'm sure most recall adrian toombs
aka vulture popped up in the morbius
trailer
and don't forget about that picture on
the wall of spider-man
with the word murderer over it now
something that's really important here
that we maybe didn't know at first when
watching the morbius trailer is that
this is
actually the sam raimi spider-man now we
caught that fact at first we realized it
was a sam raimi suit but we thought that
maybe it was just because of some
rights issues or some unknown reason but
we all actually thought that despite the
suit this is going to be tom holland
spider-man but
now that we know that spider-man 3 is
going to be a spider-verse film
perhaps this is toby maguire's sam raimi
spider-man existing in this other
universe that morbius is in
and perhaps the spiderverse is going to
be how the universes connect
instead of just acting like they exist
in the same universe there was a rumor
going around not too long ago when the
spider-man
disney sony deal was finally settled and
the rumors were
that sony could put sony characters such
as venom and
morbius in spider-man films in the mcu
however they could only go into the mcu
if they were only in spider-man films
meaning venom or morbius or any other
character couldn't show up in
any other film that wasn't a spider-man
film this makes it entirely possible for
morbius and
venom to appear in spider-man 3. and if
we're going to have a bunch of villains
cameoing and taking on spider-man in the
third film why not have
venom and also keep in mind this could
be set up before we actually get to
spider-man 3 which is a year from now
morbius is releasing early 2021 and
venom 2 let there be carnage is supposed
to be coming out in october
clearly morbius based off of the trailer
that we saw is going to have some sort
of
tie-in to spider-man 3. we have adrian
tombs as vulture actually talking to
morbius in one of the scenes they showed
spider-man on the wall
and they have shown the daily bugle in
some leaked photos from the morbius set
that we have seen
so they are connecting the universes so
we may get a little glimpse of the
spider-verse before we actually get
spider-man 3.
and then we have venom 2 let there be
carnage set to come out just
a couple of months not even before
spider-man 3.
and since morbius exists in the same
universe that venom does
and morbius is tying into the mcu
somehow that means venom's universe is
tying into the mcu somehow as well so i
wouldn't actually be surprised if we see
a tom holland or spider-man cameo in
venom 2
only a quick one though perhaps at some
point in time in venom let there be
carnage or in the post-credit scene of
the film
eddie brock and venom are watching the
news the daily bugle
j jonah jameson pops up on the screen
and they see the report about spider-man
and peter parker and that would set up a
very smooth way for venom to appear in
spider-man 3 and then hopefully go
head-to-head against spider-man in
another film
later on because unfortunately right now
spider-man 3 is going
to have so many characters we probably
won't get a venom vs spider-man battle
but simply a venom cameo
so let's hope this rumor is true because
i know a lot of us would really love to
see venom and spider-man finally
interact
and inside of the mcu so be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos as soon as i hear
more i'll be sure to update everybody
don't forget to like the video and let
me know how excited you are for
spider-man 3 and the possible cameo of
venom and morbius in the comments down
below
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof